we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
hey hey here we are folks we're on the
patreon you're on the patreon welcome
you know what it is you know where it is
good to have you back
good to be back i'm eating a pretzel
again yeah well we've had a couple of
cocktails so you're seeing the real
sausages made
however good to be here man should we do
some questions let's do some questions
the people want to know they're writing
in what do you got
dominic adamson favorite marlon brando
performance besides the godfather
godfather ain't my favorite brandon
i'm going on the waterfront all day baby
i love street car but
a lot of french like my
on the waterfront's as good as it gets
baby that's a hot that's a hot movie
he's a sexy man he's yeah he's a bad boy
yep yeah isn't he like a biker guy in
that
well it's like a gang yeah i mean he's
like you know he's like a
longshoreman type oh right right he's a
dock worker yeah but
one i think what's the one where he's a
biker guy with the leather cap which one
is that i don't know i i like i'm going
louisiana pride i i like stella
streetcar
yeah yeah he was a real loose cannon
that ripped hot so animalistic primal
sweaty always wet he had like a tiny
white t-shirt come on yeah he was hot in
that i'm going on the waterfront for me
but i i just think it's like a perfect
movie but um
either way it's elia kazan who named
names
stunkin superman he was weird as jarrell
he would just not it was like you saw in
that document when he got over all he
didn't like he was like go [ __ ] yourself
like the director he was like you don't
get this yeah it's like a [ __ ] hot
chick like oh you think you earned this
right right he knew who he was he knew
he was a [ __ ] uh like a titan of the
of of the hollywood industry he was
[Music]
scott miller road runner the anthony
bourdain dock is my wreck interviewees
are mostly his crew from parts unknown
really [ __ ] good i actually heard
this was great and i can't wait to watch
it i can't do it come on i'm just i
haven't fully accepted it it's tough
like a lot of people i really who i felt
connected to have died over the years in
in in their work i mean like kobe dying
[ __ ] hit me like a ton of bricks and
then bourdain same [ __ ] i mean
i still watch the show i do i watch the
show too it's tough to like be like oh
this is the final i don't know yeah i'll
probably watch it at some point i'm so
impressed with the guy because as a
comic
who always thinks he has to be on and
funny and writing and working he was so
natural on the show like he's not really
you know this
regis philbin hey guy how we doing you
know he just he was just mellow and cool
and that's what i loved about it that
was so rare for tv yeah just to be that
authentic and normal and like not trying
he had a a subtle coolness about him so
i wasn't even that subtle he was just
cool right it was cool he was just a
cool guy who did jiu jitsu and drank
yeah food was a former addict and yeah
[ __ ] rock change
[Music]
with the kitchen confidential yeah and
you know the show blew up on the travel
channel which says so much about how
good it was
good point standing out on ciso you know
it's not exactly like a hot place to you
know crush it so yeah bourdain rules
yeah he might have put travel on the map
much like hitler with the history
channel
weird reference but hitler put travel on
the map too it was just invasion
poland
do benjamin boyer saw a pig because you
guys and loved it on the top of nick
cage doing [ __ ] or gold have you seen
mandy thoughts i loved it i haven't not
seen mandy i saw it i didn't love it
what is mandy it's a revenge movie it's
a guy who nick cage it's it's
interesting and it's well shot and it's
cage being loony it it's not bad
i like pig way better really
i loved it yeah it's great i loved it i
thought it was shot well i thought it
was just a great thriller
uh
really pretty looking interesting
completely original i like that he's
kind of broken but he doesn't
get angry like it's really just about
psychological uh
like he takes people down with his mind
rather than just like murdering everyone
yes yes exactly like that scene where he
got beat up
he just took it yeah you came and you
saw
it just felt like a little it felt like
an indie
it felt like they were indie but then
also kind of it was still kind of like
formula revenge flick it wasn't bad it
just wasn't like
you know it wasn't bad it's another kind
of pacific northwest type
movie interesting it's kind of the anti
the anti-pig
oh anti-pig somebody doesn't like cops
keith zinc science
that's got to be german
what what are the guys death row meals
oh
see this is a tough question i'm bad at
these because they put you on the spot
it's do or die
what are you going to have
it's hard not to go like steak
fries
that's too hacky you think i don't like
steak that much
i like steak
it's all the one thing the first bite
tastes like the last bite i don't know
it's to me there's nothing it's just i
can do one bite of steak or five bites
what's the difference is hacky but it's
hacky for a reason you know how about
this and it's hacky i just don't like it
that much i'll throw some more to see
guys join the patreon right now at
patreon.com we might be drunk get on the
after party i think i just broke this
there you go you get emails tell us your
wrecks your jokes your drinks we'll open
boxes you're missing out folks all the
good stuff's on the patreon tell a
friend
you